there are lots of creative people a new
University
and any number of cafes and bars
everything's accessible by foot or by
bike
the university is located in the heart
of the city leipzig is teaming with
students one of them is Annika Rika
right now she and her boyfriend
Christian Allah are planning a short
trip first stop
Berlin but they don't have much money
we've only got 200 euros so let's keep
our travel costs low I don't want to
spend a lot of money on travel it's not
necessary they decide to take an
intercity bus from Leipzig to Berlin it
costs just 8 euros one-way this kind of
bus travel was introduced in Germany in
2013 and it's especially popular with
young people it's a lot cheaper than
taking the train and they've got Wi-Fi
which is great in fact it's better than
the Wi-Fi system on the trains I think
it's really cool Annika and Christian
arrived in Berlin two hours later they
have a reservation at a hostel in the
popular free Design District
but the rooms not in a building it's in
a boat and it costs just 19 euros a
night per person
after they unpack their gear they head
for the eastside gallery it's one of the
last remaining stretches of the berlin
wall and it's been painted by more than
100 artists
that evening they check out the
nightlife around Bosh house Casa then
they stopped by Zeeman dock Strasse
where there are lots of bars and cafes
during the summer nearly 2,000 people
can sit outside here
if there are so many different people
here different scenes and all kinds of
music it's great Berlin is Germany's
party capitals this was a
spur-of-the-moment trip and we've really
enjoyed ourselves so far there's a lot
going on here let's see how the evening
goes next the couple head for what's
known as the raw temple it's a popular
venue for a night on the town for locals
and tourists alike
the nights in Berlin are long some
visitors spend days on end going from
Club to club but the two have other
plans
the next morning they're off to the
baltic coast they're hitching a ride
with another student for just 10 euros
each
but thumbing a ride is so last century
these days you can book a lift on the
Internet drivers can advertise any
available seats in their cars on travel
portals
these Shera ride services are also very
popular with young people because
they're inexpensive and environmentally
friendly
three hours later they arrived at a
campground near vana Munda
one night at the campground will cost
about 30 euros for both of them and
they're just a few steps from the Baltic
few things are as relaxing as sunshine
the sea and a beach it's a world apart
from party central in Berlin Annika and
Christian calculate the cost of their
trip so far so if we add up travel costs
food the hostel and the campground and
one night of partying in Berlin it comes
to a hundred and sixty euros so far
we've got about 40 euros left and that's
about what we expected just enough to
get us back home plus something from the
bakery for breakfast perfect and so as
the Sun sets over the Baltic Sea our two
travellers decide that it's possible to
enjoy a nice little getaway without
spending a fortune